in a perfect world if this were a rubber
ball and i dropped it down to the floor
it would bounce up to the same height if
it was completely elastic but it would
go
in practice to a lower height and then a
lower height and lower height and lower
this object apparently is called a
dropper popper it has a little rod at
the top and it has some rubber that
comes down this way only you can bend it
the other way and it has two states
which are quite stable that state
and that state and what i'm going to do
is put it into this state and drop it on
the floor
giving it a spin so that it remains in
the horizontal plane
and if i do this and drop it are you
filming it now brady
it bounces up and i can catch it even an
old man like me and if i drop it from
this height
it goes up higher
than the height from which it was
dropped
[Music]
this at first
made me addicted to it because i
couldn't work out why it was doing this
because it seemed extremely strange that
you would be able to drop this
and catch it
and it goes up higher than before and i
also learned that i could do it with
both hands and i've been trying to do it
with both hands i catch it but it's
impossible
on
when it's at this height we say it has
energy because i've done work lifting it
up to this height
so there is an energy due to its
position
and as i drop it on the floor if it
bounced elastically it would come up to
the same height
the thing which is surprising is that it
goes further what happens is you deform
this you have to really push hard on
this and to get it to go into that state
it requires quite a bit of work to get
into that state and it always if i tip
it back it'll go back automatically into
that state so you started off in this
state which has cost you a bit of work
because you have to force yourself to do
it now when it drops down and it hits
the floor
it can go into the other state if it
whacks down hard enough so if i were to
do this from a very low height
nothing happens if i drop it from this
height
then it bounces much higher when it
lands
it hits the floor
suddenly
the central pillar comes out hits the
floor and pushes up
and it jumps in the air
this is releasing energy because if this
state requires you to do work that state
has a lower energy lower potential
energy and that energy is released by
pushing on the floor and raising up
higher
to change it to the other configuration
i had to pull on this rubber and extend
the molecules of the rubber and do work
on it and if i do that and get it to a
certain point it will click over
and now i've stretched
these rubber molecules a little bit it's
it's much more taut you can feel that it
doesn't move so much when it hits the
ground the top of this dome
suddenly gets inverted becomes a dome
pointing the other way and that pushes
this rod down
and then it hits the floor and bounces
up
[Music]
when you have
any object like this and you spin it the
angular momentum
of the spin remains constant and keeps
the axis about which it rotates vertical
and that's what i'm trying to do
like a spinning top so that when it hits
the floor i'm hoping that it i haven't
twisted sideways by any little bit and
therefore when it falls down it's likely
to release the maximum amount of energy
because it's
hitting and
somehow
on all faces at the same time and coming
up if i had it coming down a hitting on
the side
well you can see that can still work but
it just flew out of my hand one way
[Music]
the things the central locking device
the range can be extended if you place
the key against your head i really
wanted to know whether this is true but
i couldn't believe it oh wow
you didn't tell me it was this cool
look at this
ah
i totally feel like indiana jones right
now this is amazing
look at that